today's topic so we made a video a
couple weeks back
you know talking about how black people
uh can also be
excuse me excuse me
it's all systemic so
black people cannot be here's the thing
right and so when we made that video so
many people got mad
and they're like no we don't have the
institutional power etc etc
um and i had one girl dropping my dms
one time she got super upset
uh who told you you can make this kind
of statement uh
there are social sociologists who've
studied this stuff who've done the work
and done the research and yes and
there's other sociologists who disagree
with them
here's the thing i don't understand
what's so complicated about what we said
based off the webster dictionary
which is the definition that most people
operated on for a long time
that it includes prejudice it includes
all right and the definition is pretty
simple all this systemic and
institutional power that you guys are
talking about
that's come afterwards and it's not a
definition that's been acknowledged by
most people
i don't understand why the idea of
individual racism is such a foreign
concept to people
if racism couldn't happen on an
individual level why would you invent
terms like institutionalism
and systemicism to differentiate the
different forms of
you put those prefixes because you
understand
that there are different manifestations
of that thing
right and so we can't look at this and
be like oh this definition doesn't makes
why would you guys use this and act
oblivious to why people don't subscribe
to this university type definition
when in reality most people have never
subscribed to them
that's the first thing the second thing
is i don't understand what the point of
that dialogue is one can acknowledge
that
the dominant society has more abilities
to be impactful with terrorism and also
recognize
that individuals from a less dominant
society can also be missed
it's like it's like you know i wouldn't
go up to a white person who's grieving
over the last one and i ask
how did they die and the person's like
well it was a hate crime the racist
black guy
cut off his head and then strung it
around and said i hate white people
and he's a racist he's foul i wouldn't
be like well actually he's just
prejudiced
like what's the point of adding that to
the conversation you can acknowledge
that certain groups are better at it and
also still say it's the same sport
you know what i'm saying it's like when
i watch basketball in thailand i don't
go like that's not basketball
just because black knit people can do it
much better it's still the same story
everybody knows pee wee hockey and
hockey you know what i'm saying
it's just you ever seen thailand
basketball okay they're trying
god bless them you know i mean shout out
to my filipinos you know what i mean
i respect you guys but it's still the
same sport i would invest them in thai
boxing
they said they murk in there remember
that video of the asian guy who was
getting beaten up by black people
and like we hate asians and they were
beating him up and they were throwing
stuff at him
prejudice and then people were like oh
my gosh and then a whole bunch of black
people came outside
uh actually what we're looking at
is a manifestation of white supremacy
because the reality
of black people is that black people
cannot be
for when you live in systems of
inequality there is no way for you
to engage in equal type of action
brother this is just a reaction
to the asian people being bad to black
people
fight the power this is abba
zaba zulu kang
get the [ __ ] out good morning [ __ ] says
[ __ ] sir don't get
your hotep ass out of here get the [ __ ]
out of here
no black people cannot be yeah it's just
like there
could not be effective therefore it does
not exist
it's like saying a woman can't be
violent against a man
because women are physically less strong
these kind of arguments are bad
it's not because they're not the less
effective at it then they cannot you
know slap the [ __ ] out of you exactly
so one can acknowledge the reality of
systemic one can acknowledge
institutional
you can acknowledge all these aspects
and also recognize that
even though you're a minority and you
have less power you can still engage in
that behavior
on a smaller scale still the same word
and it just
i don't know it just seems very
disingenuous and seems very slimy
to come into a conversation where
someone suffered a hate crime and be
like yeah
it wasn't just prejudice i don't know
if someone who's a minority says white
people are inferior they're disgusting
and their pigmentation is an abomination
and black folks are the superior race
that's the textbook definition and i
know this to be true
because right now there are activists
trying to change
the dictionary definition to include the
institution on the systemic aspect
so didn't acknowledge that this
definition exists and that's the most
used one they wouldn't try to change the
dictionary
so and just whenever i see this talk it
just it is it's not
it's not conducive to good dialogue what
did you want to say about this whole
black people can't be
oh just it's a possibility i've seen it
happen yeah
okay it's not gonna permit you
to have a better job but it's still
there it's still
the act is theirs not as effective but
it's still there
black people can be i was having this
conversation with someone
about this thing is that exactly that
person was like no black people cannot
be
yes they can no because whenever they
hate
they hate white people they not because
they feel superior
to them and if they do it's mental
issues
i headed out i'm like i i'm out
you to hear something funny go ahead you
know how they always say like police
police is a institution yeah and that
police officer is a reflection of that
institution yeah
what do they always say about black cops
they're the same they're part of the
institution or they're oftentimes worse
than the white counterparts absolutely
so when those black cops are enforcing
that
institution are they engaging in
prejudice
to me it's just i'm trying to keep your
job
but that's that argument that's their
they're saying that's what they say
yeah so i'm like okay well would you
look at uncle ruckus and saying he's
being prejudiced when he's do
she hates black people he thinks they're
inferior he thinks they're inferior
he's just prejudice yeah you can
internalize
but you can't externalize it
i don't know man it's just to me just
it's communicating sometimes
yeah they don't hear themselves talk out
loud it's like when you say stuff like
that
say it out loud just repeat it a few
times you know what i mean and then
sometimes americans will get off and
they'll be like
well you know what you're not from here
so you don't what do you guys think that
only existed in america but it is do you
think that slaveries only exist in
america
it's america humane do you not realize
that in the usa do you not realize that
they're still slaves in parts of africa
right now
look at libya you guys don't have a
monopoly on what it looks like you don't
have a monopoly on the definition no but
they're the best at it
i don't know it's just when i hear this
stuff i'm like
and just ugh
this is not an excuse we're not keeping
for white folks it's just
when i'm having a discussion and someone
stops like uh when you're discussing
these hate crimes just understand it's
prejudice
like first you're not helping anything
to the conversation you're not adding
anything
it doesn't it doesn't make the situation
evolve or
the understanding of what's going on it
doesn't yeah it's just
you know some it's like when you were
walking papa
you were watching pop-up videos like i
don't care if the song men
went out with the sister of their lead
singer i don't care
that's what you're doing oh did you know
that i don't give a [ __ ]
you're not helping the conversation it
doesn't go further
it doesn't do anything you're just
stalling the conversation
and it's mental masturbation that you're
doing look i know
get out of here and if you look at the
definition of prejudice and the
definition
in the dictionary it's included in the
definition of yes
so i don't know so anyways that's all
our thoughts hopefully we never have to
cover this topic again let us know what
you guys think in the comments below
[Music]
foreign